now there is a lot of excitement in
cameroon where the 33rd edition of the
africa cup of nations tournament is
kicking off on sunday now the african
football confederation has set really
strict protocols for afghan or
spectators must be fully vaccinated and
show a negative pcr test less than 72
hours before a match
now stadiums can only fill up to 60
capacity but there is a but there will
be an increased capacity to 80
when cameroon's national team plays
now the tournament begins with cameroon
taking on burkina faso at the olympic
stadium in yaounde and i'll be talking
to our reporter there after this report
cameroonians are already dancing in the
streets
the spirit of football is in the air
and everywhere you look the host
nation's flag is sure to be seen
and local fans hope the indomitable
lands can win their sixth afghan title
on home soil
i am very proud of the work my country
has put into hosting the tournament
after a very long time
[Music]
i would like my cameroonian brothers the
lions to win this afcon i also hope it
boosts our economy
but the last time they hosted the
tournament back in 1972 they failed to
win
however striker eric maxim trooper
moting hopes they can make fans happy
of course it's an honor to play to play
the nation's cup at home and it's
it's a special thing of course for the
whole nation
and
we want to go as far as possible that's
clear we have we have a good squad a
good team we're a big nation of football
in africa and um
it's special definitely
the most successful country in the
history of the tournament is egypt with
seven titles followed by cameron's five
and defending champions algeria have won
it twice
led by manchester city's riyad mahrez
the foxes have not lost a game since
november 2018 and recently won the arab
cup while extending their on beating
streak
egypt are going to the afghan with one
of the world's most recognized players
in mohamed salah
the liverpool striker scored 24 goals in
the premier league in 2021
the 24 teams have been drawn into six
groups
the top two teams from each group
along with the four best third place
teams are guaranteed a sport in the last
16.
but the tournament has been troubled by
construction delays
as well as the covenanting pandemic that
led to its postponement
the crisis in the anglophone region with
a separatist group clamoring for an
independent country has led to more than
three thousand deaths and more than a
million people displaced recent attacks
in the city of bureau not far from limbe
one of the host cities has created
safety fears
it's in this same context that we
managed the african nations championship
a few months ago so i can't reveal here
the measures that are being put in place
but you should know that just like that
tournament took place under very good
conditions
the afcon will also take place under
very good conditions there are no
worries there's nothing to worry about
cameroon will hope that the next four
weeks of football go without a hitch
as it puts on a show for the world to
remember
and i'm now joined by our reporter
blaise ayong who is in cameroon for us
today
hi blaze it's good to see you how
serious is the security threat for this
tournament
thanks christine
observances
remains a big problem for the african
corporate nation uh you know one of the
stadiums which is which is hosting this
uh tournament is in the anglophone
region where there has been conflicts
raging for over five years
uh on wednesday a bomb went off
and that was just less than a week ago
another bomb had went uh had gone off in
limbe
and and a lot of people that we spoke to
in the city say that they fear that uh
the separatists may carry a bomb into
the stadium in limbo and attack
supporters
uh fans that have come to watch the
games and even teams that are playing in
limbo so security remains a big concern
but not just in limbo also in the west
region because the west region is close
to the northwest region of cameroon and
northwest region is the epicenter of the
anglophone conflict and some believe
that the teams that are playing in the
west region in the town of babusan may
be attacked by separatists actually
cameron is facing the prophet uh
security threats from boko haram though
boko haram has never been
attacked the city of gabra in recent
history but there is also that
analysts say there's a potential that
something like that may happen so uh we
cannot say for sure what would happen in
the days ahead but security remains a
big problem
and has the government responded to this
security threat how have they responded
to the security threat
for the anglophone region the government
has uh put in place a lot of soldiers in
towns like boya limber these are towns
in the southwest region of cameroon
where the tournament will be taking
place one of the cities where the
tournament will be taking place so uh
the last time that i was there i saw and
i saw lots of amok because i saw tanks
on the street it looked to me like a war
scene and when ministers and all that uh
calf delegation go to inspect the the
stadium in limbe you see a huge number
of soldiers uh surrounded around around
the stadium so government is government
says they are not taking anything for
granted that they put in place security
measures to keep the separatists away
who is favorite to win this time around
it is hard to say cameron has a lot of
advantage because cameron is hosting
cameron is hosting this uh tournament
after they lastly did so 50 years ago so
there's a huge supporting camera but you
also have very strong things with
good players like senegal where you have
money you have the nigerians
you have a lot of teams that have
potential and you also have the north
african teams which are sometimes seen
always seen as the favorite for the
african couple of nations so uh i would
want cameron to win because it's my
country but i think the competition is
going to be tough and let's expect
surprise because we are seeing the likes
of zambia win the african cup of nations
in the past
yeah and let's hope zimbabwe will make
some history there
in cameroon please it's good to talk to
you as always
thank you